you're taking wrestling classes I am oh
yeah that we have a picture of you with
your wrestling class why are you doing
that
I started getting a wrestling class
because I was like we wouldn't stand up
comedy things getting a little too
stable you know regular check something
that I could possibly break my neck in
for like $20 yeah but mostly just
something I've always wanted to grow I
just love wrestling I'm sure you as you
know I've been fan my whole yeah you're
a huge wrestling fan so I was like oh
let me try it before I'm too old to do
it all right
yeah what are you learning you're
anything good yeah learn how to do lock
ups headlock takeover it's gonna lock up
just like you just would get my you're
ahead of mine you just grabbed my neck I
could tell you yeah show it to me yeah
okay so first you've gotta end up your
boss at Wachovia
[Applause]
you can't be giving away any money I'll
show you
settle down Ronda you gotta come at the
same time what do I do
and then one hand on my oh okay I got
you right there and I have one hand on
your neck well your elbow and then it
can go tough away and I could bring you
in and now you're in the headlock and I
got you
that is your birthday present
yeah yeah you got to get your rage out
at the bank happy birthday
oh it's 5:00 I wanted to do that to a
white man in the suit
[Applause]
you